من يومين بدي اعمل المنتدى الاقتصادي
العالمي في دابوس بسويسرا الاجتماع السنوي
للنخب السياسيه والاقتصاديه في العالم
واللي بيناقش
وطبعا القضايا العالميه ان كان من الحرب
الى تغير المناخ وتركير التكنولوجيا على
الامن الى النمو الاقتصادي العالمي وهكذا
طبعا مثل ما قلت لكم هو اجتماع مو بس
القاده السياسيين لا كمان بيكون من ضمن
المدعوين رجال الاعمال معروفين حول العالم
فالمنتدى السنه في 52 رئيس دوله وحكومه
و600 رئيس تنفيذي ورجل اعمال من حول
العالم المنتدى الرسوم العضويه في اكثر من
140,000 دولار في السنه واللي بده يحضر او
يبدا يحضر هذا المنتزه تحديدا الامور
والجهل له دعوه بيدفع الاف الدولارات لكن
اهم رجل في العالم او رجل اعمال في العالم
مو شايفين احنا هناك احنا طبعا بنتكلم على
رجل الاعمال
على الفيديو ديسمبر انه تم الدعوه الى
المنتدى او لكن هو رفض الدعوه وكان غرد
ورد على تغريده في نفس الشهر كمان وقال
انه هو ما بيروح على المنتدى مول لانه
متورطين في مخططات شيطانيه لكن لانه
يبدلوا ممل لكن ومها افتتاح المنتدى اداره
وفتحت النار على ماسك وحولت الموضوع لحرب
وجبها وقالت له احنا اللي اصلا ما عزمناك
المتحدث باسم المنتدى قال انه اخر دعوه
توجهت لاله الماسك لم تكن هذا العام وليست
مؤخرا قال انه اخر مره في عام 2015 وانه
اسمه السنه اصلا ما كان بين المدعوين ومن
وقت ما بدات اعمال المنتدى وقال للمسك
جالس بيرد على فيديوهات متداوله وتغييرات
حوله وبيسخر من المنتدى وخصوصا من بعد هذا
التصريح فغرد جدا على فيديو من افتتاح ذا
فويس ورد عليه هذا ماسك وقال انه لازم
نعمل برنامج مسابقات فكره ونقول للناس
الجمل بيحاولوا انه يحذروا فعلا في دابوس
ولا في شامفور طبعا اللي ما يعرفها
تشارفور هو موقع على الانترنت مشهور
بالترويج لنظريات المؤامره اللي ما لها اي
اساس او حقيقي